une association avec l'EPS à mon avis
serait contre nature aujourd'hui étant
donné que la politique nationale n'est
absolument pas une politique ni
écologique ni sociale ni solidaire et ni
démocratique puisque toutes les lois qui
sont mises en route maintenant le son à
l'insu je dirais des citoyens qu'on
souhaite d'ailleurs ces élections pour
voir construire dans les cantons dans
les villes de notre canton j'irai
d'essayer de construire des
rassemblements citoyens à partir
de nos sensibilités politiques
différentes mais ouverte à tout le monde
et c'est à dire d'une autre façon dire
de repartir du local pour reconstruire
quelque chose pour que les gens se
réapproprient la politique et qu'ils
aient une autre vision du politique